bonsoir à tous dans l'actualité ce soir
le durcissement du conflit des retraites
les syndicats de la sncf appellent à
leur tour à une grève reconductible dès
mardi prochain
même mot d'ordre a eu des trous dans la
chimie quelles conséquences et quelle
réaction au sommet de l'état question à
sophie brune et à michaël darmon à
l'elysée la hongrie confronté à une
marée rouge dernier bilan 7 morts ou
disparus après l'accident industriel
l'europe s'inquiète car le danube sera
sans doute contaminés arnaud boutet et
sur place a battu mais pas vaincu c'est
la première réaction de jérôme kerviel
après sa lourde condamnation
ce soir la société générale lui tend la
main pour trouver un compromis sur les
dommages et intérêts dominique
verdeilhan sera en direct l'alertent de
la banque mondiale sur l'envolée des
cours des matières premières agricoles
le prix du blé a presque doublé en trois
mois
bonne opération pour la france les
menaces de crises alimentaires dans le
monde c'est le dossier de cette édition
la ruée sur les crédits immobiliers les
taux d'intérêt ont atteint cette semaine
leur niveau le plus bas depuis
l'après-guerre 3,30 % enfin le boom du
discount chic h&m qui s'installe sur les
champs elysées zara ou gap plébiscité
par les ados quelle est la recette du
prêt-à-porter pas cher notre enquête
tout à l'heure bienvenue dans ce journal
cette fois c'est une certitude le
conflit des retraites est donc engagé
dans une nouvelle phase après la ratp
après le secteur maritime la sncf où le
secteur de l'énergie entrent dans la
danse
les préavis sont reconductibles
autrement dit la grève pourrait être
prolongée de jour en jour à partir de
mardi prochain précision romain mais si
alexis delcourt
un trafic perturbé et des voyageurs à
quai plusieurs jours de suite c'est le
pari des cheminots de la sncf
réunis cet après midi les quatre grands
syndicats cgt cfdt sud rail et unsa
appellent à une grève reconductible à
partir du 12 octobre prochain une montée
en tension dans la bataille contre la
réforme des retraites
et si les cheminots ne seront pas
concernés dans l'immédiat il assume
cette radicalisation
nous on souhaite montrer l'exemple aux
autres salariés ont montré la voie et
donné qu'il nous rejoigne effectivement
mouvement un gouvernement qui ne veut
rien entendre qu'ils restent
complètement sourd aux exigences de
mouvement qui est soutenu rappelons le
par 71 % de la population
il va falloir évidemment peut-être
mettre braqués aujourd'hui au dessus et
donné une autre dimension ou aux mains
il y a deux jours à la ratp les
syndicats ont déposé un préavis de grève
illimitée à partir du 12 octobre
elle pourrait toucher les transports en
commun un peu partout en france
appel à la grève également de la cgt
dans les secteurs du gaz et de
l'électricité ou encore dans les
raffineries de total
un mouvement auquel pourraient se
joindre les chauffeurs routiers
force ouvrière et sud les invite
aujourd'hui à une grève reconductible
ce soir dans leur bras de fer avec le
gouvernement les opposants à la réforme
affichent leur détermination
les leaders syndicaux eux gardent le
silence bonsoir sophie brune vous êtes
en direct de la gare du nord à paris
cette radicalisation
c'est un pari des syndicats et notamment
de la cgt
oui david c'est un pari ambitieux les
syndicats veulent vraiment continuer et
amplifier l'épreuve de force qui l'ont
lancée face au gouvernement alors on l'a
vu la cgt est en pointe dans ce combat
ce qui est remarquable ce soir c'est que
les préavis dépasse les secteurs un
petit peu traditionnelle il n'y a pas
que les transports ou la fonction
publique on l'a vu les mines l'énergie
peut être demain aussi la métallurgie
appelle à des grèves reconductibles
c'est tout à fait inhabituel ce qui
semble montrer que la cgt a l'intention
de lancer un maximum de forces dans
cette bataille est cependant c'est un
pari évidemment risqué pour les
syndicats difficile d'abord de savoir si
les salariés vont les suivre si les
salariés sont prêts à perdre plusieurs
jours de salaires dans un contexte
économique tendu ni
il aussi de savoir si le gouvernement
ces prêts à fléchir face à cette menace
sophie brune à la gare du nord merci
sophy quelle réaction précisément au
sommet du pouvoir
on va aller dans un instant à l'elysée
d'abord voyons comment ce mot d'ordre a
été accueilli à la sncf ou dans les
autres secteurs concernés il zinc à
florian lemoal avec nos bureaux en
région
ils sont cheminots à paris gare de lyon
conducteur ou agents d'accueil
ils viennent d'apprendre l'appel des
syndicats une grève reconductible
en tant que cheminot ils ne seront
touchés par la réforme qu'à partir de
mais pour la prochaine grève même
illimitée ceux là sont partants je
préfère perdre de l'argent maintenant
plutôt que travailler six années plus
travailler à 100 vous vous rendez compte
mais ce travailleur de 8 noeuds que je
me lève à 4 heures du matin à des
semaines à semaine d'après je finis à 23
heures si on dit rien ça veut dire qu'on
accepte et il ya beaucoup de gens qui
ont pas la possibilité de se mettre en
grève et qui sont d'accord avec nous et
qui sont prêts à nous soutenir à nous
rejoindre
enfin je l'espère à la gare de toulouse
même motivation même si certains agents
expriment leurs réticences
c'est pas forcément une bonne chose de
dire on va conduire le pays vers une
situation un peu critique pour arriver à
faire bouger un peu le gouvernement je
sais pas la tournure que ça va prendre
mais bon pourquoi pas un gros collectif
s'il faut en arriver là pour faire
bouger là
verre de vin pourquoi pas reste une
inconnue le taux de cheminots grévistes
pour la journée du 12 octobre et au delà
le 24 juin ils étaient 39% le 7
septembre 42 % le 23 septembre 37 %
certains agents que nous avons
rencontrés aujourd'hui nous ont
d'ailleurs indiqué qu'il ne ferait pas
grève mais ils n'ont pas voulu
s'exprimer devant la caméra en province
dans les transports urbains les
chauffeurs de bus ont eux aussi appelé à
une grève reconductible comme à bordeaux
ou à montpellier mais rien n'indique que
le mouvement sera très suivi je pense
que ma retraite c'est important après
plusieurs jours ce sera difficile autant
pour les points de vue financier
j'ai un prêt immobilier j'ai plein de
choses à payer donc voilà c'est mais je
serai parmi les participants ça c'est
sûr après la mobilisation du 12 octobre
ce seront les assemblées générales des
salariés entreprise par entreprise qui
décideront ou non de poursuivre la grève
bonsoir michaël darmon vous êtes en
direct à l'elysée est ce qu'il y a de
l'inquiétude ce soir face à ce
durcissement du conflit
tout d'abord ici à l'elysée on ne
s'étonne pas de ce durcissement c'est la
dernière bretelle avant l'autoroute
confie un proche du chef de l'état
traduire les dernières occasions avant
l'adoption finale du texte mais
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait penser
nicolas sarkozy suit avec beaucoup
d'intérêt le fait que c'est bernard
thibault le secrétaire général de la cgt
qui monte en première ligne cela veut
dire que la cgt ne veut pas n'entend pas
être débordée par sa base dans des
mouvements de grève qui concerne aussi
et souvent des secteurs qui sont pas
immédiatement justement concernés par la
réforme des retraites d'où cette analyse
que l'on murmure ici à l'elysée c'est
peut-être en fait une bonne nouvelle car
l'elysée paris sur des grèves très
impopulaire auprès de l'opinion
michaël darmon à l'elysée merci michael
une image encore des conflits en cours
la grève a été reconduite près de
marseille dans les terminaux pétroliers
et ce pour la dixième journée
consécutive on en a parlé ici même et
elle s'étend désormais aux agents du
port de marchandises ceux là même qui
avaient cessé le travail il y a quelques
jours avant de reprendre leur poste
notez que demain un pétrolier venu de
sardaigne doit ravitailler la corse qui
est en panne
gasol autre titre ce soir cet énorme
catastrophe écologique en hongrie on
l'évoquait hier les autorités luttent
contre une marée rouge
une marée de boue toxique échappé d'une
usine d'aluminium
on compte sept morts ou disparus et une
soixantaine de personnes brûlées la
pollution s'est déjà répandue dans
plusieurs affluent du danube
lionel feierstein elle s'est répandue
partout souvent les terres agricoles
dévastant les maisons de sept villages
hongrois c'est vous au crest très
toxique s'était échappé de ces bassins
de rétention ils appartiennent à une
usine d'aluminium de la région lundi ses
cuves vraisemblablement trop plein
aurait brutalement cédé sous leur poids
formant un gigantesque torrent d'un
million de mètres cubes
l'accident a fait quatre morts et 120
blessés la plupart grièvement brûlés par
les boues toxiques est mise à mal
j'ai des brûlures partout sur ma
poitrine j'ai reçu une pommade pour me
soigner mais regardez ma jambe patiente
encore les dégâts matériels sont aussi
immenses
beaucoup d'habitants tout perdu dans la
catastrophe nous avons construit ici il
y a trois ans nous avons deux enfants et
est maintenant regarder tout a été
détruit
tout est en ruine et ça et amis de même
les semailles
je pense qu'il n'y aura plus jamais de
vie ici j'en suis certain les opérations
de nettoyage ont commencé avec une
urgence empêcher que la pollution ne
gagne le danube le deuxième plus grand
fleuve d'europe
aujourd'hui plusieurs rivières sont
contaminés par l'immense fuite de
résidus d'aluminium bonsoir arnaud
bouteille vous êtes notre envoyé spécial
sur place vous êtes arrivé il ya
quelques heures arnaud qu'avez vous vu
qu avez-vous constaté là bas premier
constat je le trouve à kolontar l'un des
villages les plus touchés je peux vous
dire qu'ici tout le monde porte un
masque comme celui-ci des protections
plastiques contre cette pollution pour
venir jusqu'ici nous avons croisé
d'autres villages également le même
paysage de désolation avec des maisons
tout rouge des routes rouge de d'avant
même souvient un cortège de camions
équipés de lances à eau qui tentaient de
dégager cette boue rouge qui était
incrusté sur le sur le bitume
alors il ya beaucoup de pompiers
beaucoup de gens de pardon de militaires
également
ici l'inquiétude est bien c'est ce petit
ruisseau qui serpente dans ce village il
a été entièrement pollué et ce ruisseau
se jette dans une rivière et cette
rivière est bien sûr être un affluent du
danube est l'un des responsables de la
sécurité nous disait tout à l'heure que
le danube serait peut-être polluer
demain matin c'est important et cette
inquiétude ne touche pas que les
hongrois mais également les serbes les
croates les roumains puisque dans tous
ces pays traversés par le fleuve on
scrute attentivement depuis hier la
qualité de l'eau et on attend avec
inquiétude
arnaud boutet hongrie merci arnaud pour
ce compte rendu
en bref encore à l'étranger faut-il
parler de terrorisme ça n'est pour
l'instant qu'un soupçon
un français a été tué par balles au
yémen il s'agit du directeur logistique
d'une entreprise autrichienne et c'est
un soldat chargé de sa protection qui a
tiré dans des circonstances encore mal
définie le quai d'orsay reste prudent
par ailleurs au même moment est les
diplomates britanniques ont été attaqués
à la roquettes par des militants
présumés d'al qaïda on en vient tôt
suite du jugement rendu contre jérôme
kerviel hier avec ce paradoxe
l'amande extravagantes infligée à
l'ancien trader concentre du coup les
critiques n'ont pas sur lui mais sur la
justice ce soir la société générale sort
du silence et elle le fait dans un
esprit de compromis
loïc de la mornais mattioni veine globe
ce qui entre l'époque où jérôme kerviel
signait des autographes
celle où il salué les photographes en
sortant de prison et cette journée
d'hier où le couperet est tombé
le trader n'a plus le même aplomb pour
son unique réaction après sa
condamnation
ils semblent abattus sur la ccjc très
haut niveau durant fin quand le jugement
a été rendu la première pensée que j'ai
eu c'est pour mon père pour ma mère
pour l'instant regard du jugement qui a
été rendu hier je suis seul est
responsable
j'attendais de ce procès que profiter de
chacun fois fois reconnu tous les
supérieurs hiérarchiques de jérôme
kerviel ont quitté la banque depuis le
scandale même son pdg daniel bouton a
démissionné en juillet 2008 la
commission bancaire à sanctionner le
manque de contrôle de la banque par une
amende de quatre millions d'euros c'est
mille fois moins que les dommages et
intérêts demandés à jérôme kerviel
justement depuis la condamnation nombre
de voix s'élevaient pour réclamer à la
société générale un peu de clémence ou
de réalisme comme elle ne récupérera
jamais et sa correspondante
je trouve plus je trouverais plus ayant
pu normal qu'elle donne une deuxième
chance à jérôme kerviel et qu'elle lui
permette une fois qu'il aura purgé sa
peine si celle ci devait être confirmée
en appel de reconstruire sa vie
ce matin encore le porte-parole du
gouvernement avait conseillé à la
société générale une certaine mansuétude
mais pour la société générale ça peut
être un beau geste non il faut que le
nouveau directeur de la communication
peut-être le suggère à son président ce
soir la société générale semble avoir
entendu le message
la banque vient d'annoncer qu'elle
excluait de réclamer la totalité des 4,9
milliards à son ex trader
bonsoir dominique verdeilhan vous êtes
en direct au palais de justice de paris
donc pourquoi cette main tendue de la
société générale ce soir à écouter trois
raisons à ça la première nous les rayons
dès hier soir c'est l'impossibilité
n'est pas question de demander de telles
sommes à un homme seul a déclaré cet
après-midi un cadre de la société
générale il faut dire que cette ardoise
n'avait jamais été vu même dans des
dossiers comme par exemple celui la
catastrophe de l'erika ou de la faire f
la deuxième raison c'est que cette
indemnisation record a totalement
brouillé l'impact du jugement
on retient d'abord que la société
générale a été blanche et pour oublier
presque que jérôme kerviel a été
condamné
et puis la troisième elle est un peu
plus prosaïque c'est que jérôme kerviel
il a fait appel de son jugement
cela gèle donc non seulement tout
processus de retour en prison mais aussi
de début d'indemnisation
la décision appartient donc désormais à
des juges d'appel elle ne devrait pas
intervenir avant la fin 2011
2 min
verdoyant en direct au palais de justice
merci dominique le dossier de cette
édition maintenant le monde doit-il
s'attendre à une nouvelle crise
alimentaire depuis le début de l'été le
cours des matières premières est reparti
à la hausse de façon spectaculaire le
prix du blé par exemple la flambée de 60
à 80 % en trois mois seulement
comme souvent en de telles circonstances
le malheur des uns fait le bonheur des
autres
la france tire son épingle du jeu en
quête francis mazier bernard bonne arme
damien girolles sur le port de bordeaux
c'est du jamais vu
un immense vraquier de 125 mètres de
long venu charger dans ses cales 40
mille tonnes de blé une bénédiction pour
les producteurs français cet été en
russie incendies et sécheresses ont
détruit des millions d'hectares
les cours ont crevé les plafonds le
marché mondial a été bouleversé la
manque de production cette année en
russie à cause de la sécheresse
représente à peu près 20% des échanges
mondiaux anglais savent où le verset le
flux de marchandises conséquences pour
le port de rouen + 20 % des exportations
vers l'algérie le maroc l'egypte le
yémen et plusieurs pays de l'afrique de
l'ouest
bordeaux a rapidement ouvert une route
maritime vers alexandrie l'egypte
s'approvisionnaient essentiellement en
russie
elle se tourne désormais vers le blé
français plus cher mais bien meilleurs
de l'avis d'un expert envoyé à bordeaux
c'est très bon rien meilleur que le blé
russe dans lequel on trouve toutes
sortes d'insectes vivants ou morts alors
que ce blé l'ap est excellent ça c'est
vraiment la super la super qualitair
voit pas la protéine ici mais
c'est un élément déterminant pour cette
année malgré tout qualité et quantité
sont au rendez vous toutes les
conditions sont requises pour développer
les exportations l'an dernier les
exportations de blé français battait
déjà des records avec près de 10
millions de tonnes
la nouvelle donne sur le marché mondial
cette année pourrait permettre de
dépasser les 11 millions de tonnes une
bouffée d'air pour cet agriculteur en
difficulté un producteurs du
lot-et-garonne qui écoulait la plupart
de son blé dans le sud ouest
cette année plus de la moitié de sa
récolte est exportée et les prix ont
flambé
on atteint des niveaux de prix
aujourd'hui qu'ils vont nous permettre
si ça se maintient dans ces conditions
actuelles de combler nos déficits de
l'année dernière et d'essayer de sortir
des bilans pour le moins positif ou au
moins à l'équilibré pour l'année
prochaine
pendant l'été la tonne de blé français
est passé de 130 à 230 euros
une envolée due en partie à la
spéculation les spéculateurs aujourd'hui
on amplifier une augmentation des prix
probablement que un tiers de la hausse
est due aujourd'hui à des fonds
d'investissement cette montée en flèche
des prix du blé peut entraîner des
dégâts collatéraux pour les éleveurs de
bétail et pour les consommateurs qui
craignent une augmentation du prix de la
baguette mais cette fois la
mondialisation a clairement favorisé les
producteurs de blé français la politique
en bref le magazine le nouvel
observateur publie la lettre des
extraits en tout cas de la lettre de
démission de bernard kouchner envoyé à
nicolas sarkozy au mois d'août
le ministre des affaires étrangères se
plaint de subir je cite des humiliations
des conseillers du président il évoque
aussi l'inflexion sécuritaire du pouvoir
et prend acte de la fin de l'ouverture à
gauche démission refusée vous le savez
bernard kouchner qui pourrait quitter le
gouvernement lors du prochain
remaniement et puis notez le on connaît
la date des élections cantonales dernier
scrutin avant la présidentielle on
votera les 20 et 27 mars de l'année
prochaine pour renouveler la moitié des
conseillers généraux
l'actualité judiciaire avec ce procès au
havre qui en rappellent d'autres celui
d'une liaison interdite
un professeur d'histoire géographie a
été jugé aujourd'hui pour avoir
entretenu une relation amoureuse avec
l'une de ses élèves
j'ai de 15 ans fanny stellaire chloé
cormery avec arnaud compte c'est
l'histoire d'une passion interdite qui
s'achève devant la justice ce professeur
d'histoire géo de 39 ans est désormais
inscrit au fichier des délinquants
sexuels durant un an il a vécu une
histoire d'amour avec l'une de ses
élèves âgé de seulement 15 ans tout
commence sur facebook où l'adolescente
demande à son professeur d'être son ami
puis la relation virtuelle devient réel
mais au bout de six mois cet enseignant
mari et père de deux enfants réalisent
que l'histoire est impossible et rompt
avec l'adolescente
j'étouffe lui qui m'avait dit un
napperon plein de choses et en fait
c'était pas la francité que du mensonge
et je me suis fait avoir franchement
c'est pas déjà en arriver là donc je
voyais heppell danger tu montes relation
causé le coeur brisé
la jeune fille se confie alors à sa mère
celle ci porte aussitôt plainte contre
le professeur qu'elle avait déjà mis en
garde
et malgré l'interdiction que je lui ai
donné que ça soye par une scène facebook
ce portable de rencontre et il a
continué à voir ma fille derrière mon
dos pas est pour nous inacceptable pour
moi c'est inacceptable en tant que maman
et lui en tant que professeur qui avec
39 ans quoi depuis l'enseignant affirme
qu'il a réalisé son air avec le recul
et il dit qu'il se laisser emballer et
regrette il va ça le transfert il
n'aurait pas dû faire ça cet après-midi
le professeur a été condamné à cinq mois
de prison avec sursis pour corruption de
mineurs il a par ailleurs été suspendu
de ses fonctions au collège l'actualité
à l'étranger avec un destin tragique et
extraordinaire qui témoigne du climat de
répression en iran vous souvenez sans
doute de cette jeune femme tuée lors des
manifestations contre le régime
elle était devenue une icône et bien une
autre jeune femme portant le même nom a
été confondu avec elle par les médias le
début d'un engrenage qui l'a finalement
mené à l'exil arnaud boutet carlos fuchs
c'était en juin 2009 lors de la révolte
iranienne
une jeune inconnue est abattu dans la
rue la vidéo de son agonie fait
rapidement le tour du monde chez son nom
neda envahi l'internet puis c'est ce
visage
neda soltani devient l'icône de la
révolution verte
tous les médias diffusent cette unique
photo récupérée sur facebook
mais tous se trompe de personne neda
soltani n'est pas morte elle vit
désormais à francfort et brandi la photo
de la victime
son homonyme ça n'est pas moi c'est neda
soltani
ça c'est moins de neda deux visages
quinze mois après la mort de neda agha
soltan l'autre neda figure encore sur
les blogs ou plus grave sur certains
sites de presse comme le journal anglais
the guardian
il refuse toujours de retirer la photo
il la conserve encore dans leurs
archives
neda a dû fuir les autorités de son pays
qui voulaient faire croire qu'il n'y
avait qu'une seule médaille qu'elle
était bien vivante
j'ai été accusé de trahison
j'ai été accusée d'espionnage et
maintenant je suis là en allemagne je
suis considéré comme une réfugiée
politique alors que je n'ai jamais fait
de politique
leda soltani enseigné la littérature
anglaise à téhéran elle doit aujourd'hui
apprendre l'allemand pour mieux
s'intégrer en classe elle se fait
appeler zara et devant ses camarades
n'évoque jamais son histoire elle n'a
revu ni ses parents ni ses amis et vous
ce fut une énorme erreur qui a détruit
ma vie
l'allemagne sera donc son nouveau pays
pour tenter de refaire sa vie à
l'étranger encore la chine au coeur de
l'actualité européenne cette semaine un
sommet union chine se tient en ce moment
à bruxelles il est question notamment
des deux églises et de la
sous-évaluation du yuan la chine qui
desserre l'étau face aux religions c'est
une nouveauté les églises évangéliques
notamment se développe à grands pas les
autorités fournissent même désormais des
terrains pour y construire d'immenses
cathédrales reportage de nos
correspondants alain de chalvron sylvain
viau
ce chantier n'est pas au texas ou dans
quelque état du sud des états unis l'ont
cette véritable cathédrale évangélique
est en construction au coeur de la chine
communiste à nankin l'ancienne capitale
le plus étonnant est que le terrain a
été donné par le gouvernement qui a
aussi tant qu'à faire contribuer à
hauteur de 20% au coût des travaux
il y est en ce moment plusieurs églises
en construction et celle ci est la plus
grande
c'est qu'il ya de plus en plus de
croyants
les églises évangéliques ont le vent en
poupe en chine comme les autres
religions mais plus que les autres elle
surfe sur le besoin de spirituel des
chinois déboussolés par la rapidité du
changement celle ci par exemple à pékin
a multiplié par dix le nombre de ses
fidèles
en sept ans les fidèles qui n'ont plus
peur de se montrer
aujourd'hui le parti et le gouvernement
se montre plus ouvert à la religion
alors qu'avant ici opposé l'état nous
donne aujourd'hui plus de liberté aux
tags six entrées au mas c'est dieu qui a
fait que le gouvernement se montre plus
tolérant ces églises évangéliques sont
alimentés discrètement par l'argent de
correspondants américains généreux ce
qui explique aussi leur succès mais le
gouvernement ne trouve rien à y redire
non plus du moment que les pasteurs
savent ou sans leurs limites
tous dans ce pays
nous avons la responsabilité de
contribuer à l'établissement d'une
société harmonieuse d'alcool mais il
n'est donc pas bon selon moi d'avoir un
discours anti gouvernementale ou contre
la philosophie dominante dans ce pays
mme fella ça fait mais il inquiète il
est malin le révérend la société
harmonieux c'est justement le slogan du
président hu jintao
ça tombe bien et ça facilite les petites
et grandes affaires
cette imprimerie notamment l la prime
que des bibles c'est la plus grosse
imprimerie de bible du monde un million
d'exemplaires par mois
en 75 langues à commencer par le chinois
la bible est un produit spécial avec une
signification particulière et notre
premier objectif est de fournir des
bibelots chinois chrétiens de répondre à
leurs besoins spécifiques
pas de tracasseries bureaucratiques au
fiscales particulières pour cette
entreprise ouvertement lié à une
fondation californienne
même si elle est l'un des principaux
instruments de prosélytisme évangélique
en chine cmao décidément qui doit se
retourner dans sa tombe
à côté de ces églises officielles il ya
les église clandestine catholique ou
protestante elle double ou triple même
le nombre de chrétiens en chine pour
elle naturellement pas de subventions
pas de répression systématique non plus
mais une constante à sécurité à
l'étranger en corps et en bref images
rarissimes d'un dresseur de lions
attaqués par ces bêtes lors d'un
spectacle en ukraine
le personnel du cirque où le voyait à
fait tout son possible pour repousser
les faux à l'aide d'un canon à eau sur
fond de cris stridents de spectateurs
paniqués
le dresseur hospitalisé avec des
blessures à un biceps et au mollet se
porte bien
il est 20 heures et 23 minutes rester
avec nous à suivre les crédits à prix
cassés les taux d'intérêt ont atteint
cette semaine leur niveau le plus bas
depuis la dernière guerre
le boom du discount chic h&m qui
s'installe sur les champs elysées zara
houga plébiscité par les ados quelle est
la recette
notre enquête dans un instant et puis en
langage branché on dit vintage
en français on parle de nostalgie
comédie musicale réédition la rentrée
ressuscite les années 70 d'abord donc ce
chiffre en apparence anodins mais qui
marque un record à la baisse regardez
c'est un taux de crédit moyen 3,30 %
emprunter de l'argent n'a jamais coûté
aussi peu depuis 1945
et c'est aussi une forte incitation à
renégocier ses échéances avec les
banques pour ceux qui sont endettés
gabriel garcia daniel levy nicolas
lajoinie est propriétaire un appartement
de 70 m² en banlieue parisienne
ici on est un principal c'est donc un
appartement vont à acheter avec ma femme
janvier 2007 pour acheter il a dû
s'endetter sur 24 ans mais depuis les
taux proposés par les banques ont
beaucoup diminué
le couple donc renégocier son emprunt à
la baisse avec à la clé de belles
économies
vous allez repartir pour 289 1000 euros
erin bingo parce qu'on va économiser 32
% par rapport à ce que vous aurait coûté
votre crédit soit 45 mille euros de
moins sur sa facture
en pratique il s'agit de contracter un
nouveau crédit avec un taux plus
intéressant exemple en 2008 pour
emprunter 100 mille euros sur 20 ans le
taux d'intérêt était de 5 75%
il vous en coûter chaque mois 720 euros
et bien aujourd'hui pour emprunter cette
même somme cent mille euros
le taux d'intérêt est passé à 3 30% il
vous en coûte chaque mois 570 euros sur
20 ans c'est une économie de 30 mille
euros mais le rachat de crédits n'est
pas systématiquement une bonne affaire
il faut réunir certaines conditions il
faut qu'il y ait au moins 1 % d'écart
entre le moment où vous avez emprunté et
le moment où vous décidez de faire
acheter votre prêt enfin les économies
réalisées diminue avec le temps dans un
emprunt vous payez d'abord les intérêts
avant de rembourser le capital
dans notre exemple au delà de 8 ans le
rachat de crédits n'est plus une
opération rentable
cela reviendrait à verser de nouveaux
intérêts à une banque selon les
professionnels du secteur
les taux d'emprunt devraient rester
exceptionnellement bas jusqu'à la fin de
l'année un phénomène de mode maintenant
il ya quelques années on évoquer le
retour des années yéyé et bien cette
rentrée 2010 voici maintenant la fureur
des années 70 mike brant joe dassin et
bien d'autres pour être branché
aujourd'hui il faut avoir l'oeil dans le
rétroviseur
les comédies musicales font le plein le
plein de fans nostalgiques
jn benzina vincent barras
ils sont tombés trop nabeul dans les
mémoires comme dans les bacs à disques
les artistes des années 70 se frottant
retour sur les scènes parisiennes 35 ans
après son dernier concert mike brant est
à nouveau à la fiche en pleurant
un tour de perruques et ce jeune
comédien devient mike brant
on se sent vraiment aimé quoi la péruse
plus les habits de lumière ça fait que
lorsque le rideau s'ouvre on entend des
eaux
mike brant a vendu 15 millions d'albums
en seulement cinq ans de carrière
comme ça
puis sa mort le chanteur figure parmi
les meilleures ventes
cent soixante dix mille cd écoulés
chaque année
ensuite ces rencontres et aussi par joe
dassin son fils lui rend hommage le
temps d'un spectacle musical
une vraie nostalgie les artistes de
cette époque mais il ya aussi que dans
les années 70 il y avait des vraies
chansons avec des vrais textes qui
parler aux gens
malade appel
ambiance et un peu assez morose en ce
moment donc forcément cette période
c'est plus léger avec mamma mia d'abba
qui débute fin octobre les chanteurs
rétro n'ont pas fini de le dire qu'ils
veulent être
oui
en bref on a appris la mort de la
chanteuse et actrice colette renard
colette raget de son vrai nom a
enregistré 52 disent qu'ils ont souvent
été de très grand succès populaire
elle a triomphé en interprétant plus de
mille fois dans le monde entier le
personnage d'irma la douce un extrait
pour le plaisir et sciences
jamais
eaton qui m'amène
ce qui
en
navet
vous pouvez tout
oh
on va
c'était le ponde caulaincourt colette
renard avait 86 ans avant de refermer ce
journal je vous en rappelle l'un des
principaux titres le durcissement du
conflit des retraites les syndicats de
la sncf appellent à leur tour à une
grève reconductible dès mardi prochain
même mot d'ordre ou dans la chimie
d'autres secteurs pourraient prendre
également le relais dans les jours qui
viennent et puis cela fait 2 181 jours
qu'hervé ghesquière et stéphane taponier
ainsi que leurs trois accompagnateurs
sont retenus en otage en afghanistan
nous ne les oublions pas voilà pour la
mode à petit prix ce sera sans doute
pour l'édition de demain merci à vous
tous tout de suite la météo laurent
romejko nous annonce le retour du beau
et du show 20h35 votre nouvelle série
les vivants et les morts avec robinson
stévenin et marie denarnaud notamment à
demain l'info en continu
c'est aussi sur france 2 pourrait faire